now you can build your network in luxury
at the Sterling Club the sponsors of the
segment we stopped by to learn the
benefits of their memberships my name is
Eunice verdusco I'm the director of
membership sales at the Sterling Club
the Sterling Club is a private exclusive
Club in the city of Las Vegas we have
been reopened for the last three years
we went through a very extensive Remodel
and it's really just a Hidden Gem for
our members
all right a typical day at the Sterling
club for our members includes everything
from eating at our restaurant smoking in
the Cigar Lounge getting a facial
getting your hair done in Our Salon and
Spa going to the pool playing tennis
playing pickleball
there's so many amenities that we
provide and it's just it's a little too
long to list currently we're in our
Spirits lounge and this is where most of
our live entertainment takes place so
everything that requires a little bit of
a larger setup like a band setup takes
place in here we have supper club in
here uh we Host movie Nights in here and
this space is also available for private
events
remember you don't have to be a resident
of Turnberry place you only have
memberships for corporate accounts the
benefits for our corporate accounts is
that they can host their business
meetings here their holiday parties
we're a great place and a great source
for businesses to conduct networking
events
um also just a lot of organic networking
takes place in our club you know you can
be sitting in the Cigar Lounge and
you're next to someone a CEO of a
company that you know you've always
wanted to reach out to we're a great
source for all businesses Our member
roster contains some of the most
prestigious residents and non-residents
of Las Vegas we provide the perfect
setting for you to mix and mingle with
like-minded individuals and you know it
we just help in creating those
relationships that are going to be good
for your business and even for your
personal life so another benefit of
corporate accounts is they can have
their corporate meetings here big or
small meetings from 10 people to
250 people with that being said we have
corporate memberships we have individual
memberships we have young executive
memberships so whether you're lawyer a
doctor a business a big Corporation a
small Corporation we have the right
membership for you we also have the Las
Vegas resident membership we have a
young executive membership we have an
out-of-state membership and Ladies If
you're looking for some self-care
throughout the day this is a great place
to unwind while the kids are at school
so you can go to our website or give us
a call or if you want just drop on by
thank you to the Sterling club for
sponsoring that segment they're right
down the street on Paradise Road and for
more information call that number on
your screen or visit sterlingclub.com
they also have a special offer going